hello and welcome
to the thing
we're doing a thing
uh my name is hans kim
and i
didn't do anything to my hair and it's
just this way
so that's kind of cool it looks kind of
like i did something to it
um my physical appearance
is something that i value very highly
um yesterday some woman uh told me that
i
smelled like ramen
so that's kind of been bothering me
um
i feel like
it's interesting
that people
would tell me that um
i uh i guess i did
go up and talk to her
um
i smell like ramen i mean it's like i
guess she wasn't trying at all
conversationally or that maybe she
didn't think i was so she didn't either
but yeah i mean um
after that happened it was like it's
hard to uh hard to
talk about anything other than that with
her
and um
then she did this thing she's like
and then she like
like spun all around me
um which i didn't find very respectful
or kind and it's just like i guess like
if you go and talk to a woman then uh
that's kind of a rude thing so they can
be rude back to you
how dare you try to [ __ ] me
i need to use it to make money off the
free market
or whatever but um yeah i mean
i think it's fine you know it's a free
country you can say what you want
this is some weed i got that was like
one interaction
and it was towards the beginning of the
the after party after kill tony
um but that was one interaction and then
like i had a bunch of interactions after
that that were positive
but you think about the negative one so
you could do better or hate people more
but yeah i mean um
it's hard to uh
like it's i guess it's a rude thing to
go up and talk to people
so then they're allowed to be rude to
you back
i mean
i don't know
anyways
i uh
yeah i mean
i uh
i think that she was a little crazy
um
i uh i think it's cool to
do the after party thing after that
woman told me i smelled like ramen
then i went uh
got some uh
shots
with these guys
uh they were like let's go to shots and
walk to the bar and then i started
talking to the girls the late the women
and then they um
then they told me i smelled like ramen
and then i uh went back to get the
people
who are gonna get me a shot
and then we did a shot together and then
he was talking about how white girls he
was having sex with a white girl he's in
a relationship with a white woman
um
[Music]
and uh how he never thought that would
happen
and that he's now living the life
and how that was like
maybe it's like he was a child and he
had internalized racism and he's like i
could never [ __ ] a white woman which is
sad they're like 70 of the population
i love hot boxing
um not really hot boxing it's a pretty
large open area so the smoke will
probably dissipate in this large
room
this is some weed that guy chris zam
gave me
uh kill tony he rolled up a joint he
rolled up a bunch of joints now i'm
smoking it it's my reward
for getting out of bed and doing
something with my life
um but
he's a
guy in san antonio he shoots a lot of
guns
he's ready for [ __ ] to go down on a very
uh specific level
um
[Music]
uh yeah so he's uh he's a gun guy
and he's apparently a trump supporter
and he smokes weed
and he was like you're gonna have to
switch your political stance if you want
to go shooting guns with me and i said i
should have said
are you gonna switch your political
stance if you're going to smoke weed
buddy
republicans are very nice to weed
smokers you should see what they do to
our kind
they jail them
for 20 years
for just having [ __ ]
um
yeah i mean uh
i uh
i was
some girl was told me i smell like ramen
i mean obviously that doesn't mean the
whole gender of women is bad or that
americans
are rude people
who
don't really care about each other
and
respect and foster
not trying hard
and just your first initial impressions
um
but yeah i mean uh it's not anything to
do with americans or women it's probably
like having to do with both and maybe
like whatever
being hot and just like being so tired
of people just trying to talk to you all
the time
um
but you know it's not really that hard
to not be tired of talking to people a
lot of people do it
i um
yeah i mean i i think that was
it was just like i don't know like
she was not really trying hard
and uh
she was just
being lazy conversationally and
in the kindness department
but i don't know it's just like
if you go and talk to girls they're like
that's
that's a cause to be mean to you now
you're talking to me
and um you know
it's true i'm very very horny
but um
that's a good thing
i mean we could all be sexless but
that's that's a sad world
um
hi hans how has psychedelics impacted
uh your life
psychedelics have uh impacted my life
thusly
in the first instance they gave me an
objective perspective on life and a
zoomed out lens from which to view
things from so that i wasn't just stuck
living my life
i could view it from another angle and
another perspective
um
so it was like the sober self
is one way of feeling and going through
life and then being high
is another way of going through life and
it informed me about my
um
it informed me about the
uh
the pros and cons of different behaviors
so that i could choose the ones that i
wanted
and
weirdly enough this is what i chose
to be super boring
um
i think that uh
the drug war is uh very bad
i'm glad i'm doing drugs i don't do
drugs too much i did do mushrooms and
smoke a bunch of wheat yesterday
but that was after the show
but yeah maybe i smoked too much weed
but
i think it was a good thing tonight i
was just like
it helped motivate me to get out of bed
because then if i have like happiness
lined up then it's easier to get out of
bed but if you're like there's nothing
i'm not gonna feel good
if i get up then it's like really hard
to get up but if since i had this weed i
was like
i know that there's gonna be some
guarantee of happiness or pleasure or
positive emotions if i get up
everything else is a crap shoot
[Music]
so it's just interesting
when you smoke people can't see your
eyes
i mean when even when i don't smoke
people can't see my eyes
this is killjoy i hate drugs except on
weekends and weekdays facts i have a
morning playlist in morning weed
i love the uh process of smoking weed i
think it's cool to be smoking something
i wish that i did a cooler there's a lot
of air when i smoke
but maybe that's good because i don't
want to get too much smoke i don't uh
want to ruin my voice
or [ __ ] up my throat
[Music]
i'm not sure i would call psilocybin
experience being high it's nothing like
weed more like seeing the other
dimensions that surround us
i think um it's a chemical it's a
chemical or a
uh
it's a chemical in your brain
that releases that makes your brain feel
different
and
depending on the chemical it has a
different effect on your brain
so
it's a chemical effect on the brain and
weed is a different
chemistry than mushrooms
and
i think it's interesting how the
different chemic goals affect you
you can't smoke weed every day
i can't roll i need to learn
um but yeah i mean
you could think of it as like seeing the
other dimensions that surround us
it's just
everything is
seeing the other dimensions that around
us and
dimensions are
like
a scientific
thing or it's not like you can just see
more dimensions but
you can have the perception that you're
seeing other dimensions
uh
but uh
it's uh i guess
i don't know i don't see my weedic or my
psychedelic experiences as like
it's like you're tapping into another
realm man
i mean i know what's happening i know
that it's just
chemicals
um i don't need to be like oh it's so
weird and stuff it's like whatever
um
deontay helm
being kind of a dick
um
i think that uh
i mean
yeah i enjoy the uh experience of uh
psychedelics
i think that uh it's good
especially if you've done it
a lot and then like
you don't naturally feel happy so you
got to do the mushrooms to experience
happiness
um but it if you
uh do it or the right amount of time
then
it's a good reminder of what happiness
feels like
if you're not experiencing it
so that you can find it when you're
sober so it's just like getting your
body used to the feeling of happiness
so that you can be more happy later
[Music]
but uh
i
i think that uh
being happy is important having emotions
is important but i don't think that
should be your goal
i think if your goal is just to feel a
certain way that's not really
us
intellectually rigorous or uh
you know it's not really
it's it's like the goal of an animal
it's like such a low goal and maybe we
should have a higher goal than like to
feel a certain way
um
i think
a more worthwhile goal is to
um
achieve a goal
intellectually and figure out what you
want and uh
yeah i feel
like uh like i want to
be successful at comedy and make a
positive impact in other people's lives
and say things that i think that are
important to say that will help people
and that are generally positive
i think that's a better goal than to
just feel good about yourself
feeling good about yourself is not a
goal it's like just a
indicator it's a signal it's like a
a byproduct of doing the right thing and
having like a good intellectual goal and
achieving it
um
he wants me to touch the thing on the
back wall
did you get it at world market this is
some uh this is my friend rachel's house
she bought all this stuff here
thanks for laughing at my sets on kill
tony pod i'll try to keep doing good
jokes
uh
i think that um
drugs are good to do
i think they make you think and
figure [ __ ] out
um i think people are afraid of drug use
because
people's minds
are a resource that needs to be
controlled
for
um
for a society for a lot of jobs for a
lot of industries
high pitched sound in the background
um
yeah i mean i get a lot of
hand jobs
well i hope
there's not too much sound in the
background
maybe i should uh
unplug it and plug it back in but then i
would lose sound for a bit
if you smoked weed they will not let you
join the military because you're harder
to brainwash
i think that
it's because they are operating from an
old way of thinking about things and
they have to have you in like an old way
that's how their brainwashing works is
if they get like a
white dude from the 50s
and uh it's just easier
to have uh
a bunch of people in the military that
think similarly and have not experienced
things and so that you're there for the
first time they experience a lot of
crazy [ __ ]
and then you can tell them what to think
but um
not saying that's a bad thing i think
that's how you train a good soldier
and i think that is a good pathway for
a lot of human beings that want to be
animals
um
animals
uh are great
i love animals
it's just like i think humans can be
more than that but that's a good way
because uh i mean the art of being a
warrior uh is
uh very very awesome and
you know cool and it's like a very
intellectually rigorous in its own way
um and
it's uh
it's a great way to use a human body and
the mind as a weapon because
at least it has a direction and
um
[Music]
yeah i mean i think it's a
cool thing to do i think it's one of the
cooler ways to use a human
um as opposed to having it like punch
numbers in an excel sheet
um
but uh yeah i mean i think
i i think that uh that's a cool
way to be i just don't think that it's
necessary right now i think
we don't have a system that uses the
military very well
and i think that
with the internet and all that
there's different
ways to do things and i mean it's simple
and it's easy and we're always gonna
need it
but uh i don't think that uh
there's a very high ceiling in that
i mean
you could be the best warrior and be
like chris kyle and like write a book
but then you're writing a book and
shooting a movie
so
uh why don't you just do that
to begin with um but yeah i mean joining
the military
is
a definite possibility
um
i just wouldn't do it now or recommend
it to anyone because uh
it's like we don't have a good history
of using the military that well i mean
vietnam and iraq
i wouldn't really want to
i mean unless i was like bloodthirsty
and just wanted to do something crazy
um but uh
and also just like i i feel like there
might be other ways to utilize the human
spirit that's more direct and more
um
addressing the issues instead of fixing
the bad stuff
i think it might be good to like make
something positive and
i think that's the future instead of
just getting really good at policing
each other
but um yeah i mean if you had to do it i
think the u.s military would be cool
because uh
it's
the best they have the most money they
have the most equipment
[Music]
i
mean more ufos are real
ufos are a topic of discussion sometimes
um i love ufos i guess
welcome peace is coming guys
good coming good guys
are in control truth is trickling out
get ready y'all
you can see the ufos in the sky what's
your favorite old school meme
i don't remember
[Music]
i would have to look through a bunch of
old school memes
um
i think ufos are not a thing
i think if there were no ufo visits
in the world we would have the same
number of ufo sightings in the in the
world
i think that there's a lot of false
sightings and people wanting to see [ __ ]
um
i don't think they visited
i don't think that uh
that they're
i don't think that they're
i don't think that um
that we should rely on them for anything
we should act like they're not there and
live our lives
because until we get our technology up
and going they're going to be so far
ahead of us
that if they don't want to be seen we're
not going to be able to see them
and to think that just like having a
telescope in your backyard and like
recording [ __ ]
is going to catch them out i don't think
that's gonna happen
but um
yeah i mean i think it's good to do that
[ __ ] for other reasons maybe catch an
asteroid
streaking across the sky
i don't think filming this guy is a bad
thing i think the more data we have the
better
um
but yeah i mean
ufos i uh
it's all masturbation
it's like
you can't really say anything one way or
the other and
it's like
i heard
you just like start telling like stories
um and then you just start like making
[ __ ] up like oh wouldn't it be cool if
they were like you know they had visited
before
um but yeah i mean it's cool to imagine
and just have an imagination contest
but
there's plenty of real world situations
that we can
have a more solid premise for instead of
like the general concept of ufos
ufos usg
um yeah i mean if they're doing their
best you know good on them i hope that
they figure it out
it's just like
what what are we supposed to do just
like come up with different theories
until
they show up and uh
like it's just it's just an exercise in
like how crazy your imagination can be
so if you want to have that that's fine
you know like take a fiction writing
class and write it write a sci-fi story
make it like a useful
uh
thing
your imagination if you're just going to
imagine ufos and tell like shitty
stories about it
but um if you if you don't actually
concretely do something about your
imagination
and you just use it to like
have uh boring conversations and like
tell long stories where people aren't
allowed to interrupt
um then i don't think that it's
a useful use of your imagination i think
you're wasting it
um and i think like they use the fact
that it might be real to then not really
be that imaginative
they're like coming up with crazy
stories but with not like
uh
with like
not that much uh
creativity because they're like the fact
that it might be real is supposed to
carry the weight
of it not being that interesting
um but yeah i mean
until it actually happens
i don't think that there's a reason to
worry about it
and i think that
i think that it's better to come up with
sci-fi stories
and usefully use your imagination
and
maybe help like come up with a new idea
for the future
that can
inform us of how to build things like
how the space
uh
this space shuttles were like they took
some ideas from like movies where
they're like oh that would be convenient
if it opened like that
or something something like that
happened i'm sure
i think i read it somewhere or heard it
somewhere
but um
yeah i mean like
think about what like our technology in
the future could do or like what an
alien meeting could look like and make a
cool movie like interstellar
or uh that other one gravity or
something
um but yeah but to just use it to like
dominate conversation
and uh you know try to fascinate people
at dinner parties i guess that's an art
form
but uh it's i feel like a lot of those
people are very lazy
artists
and uh they don't really want to commit
they want to do something that's not
really art not really science it's both
but neither
um and i think that's like a type of
person
that exists who's just like whatever
who's like not gonna do anything
um
checking my phone how is uh what are you
guys up to can you give us some thoughts
on adele canceling a residency show
i mean she's an artist
uh
she's an artist and maybe she had to
like take a day off and like reconfigure
and figure her [ __ ] out
uh what is the best art form for dinner
conversations i would say the best art
form for dinner conversations is
probably
um
[Music]
the human interest piece
like oh you do that for a living and uh
what do you do when a
596
runs into a seven four seven
and uh you know like actually being
interested in people and trying to be
like a good interviewer like a talk show
host
and uh you let them let someone else
talk and then you might maybe have a
joke over it and then
you uh let other people be the guest
show host guest show host i would say
that's
it's a better way to do it um i would
say the worst way to do it is try to
tell the longest stories possible
and
now that anyone else talk just try to
talk for as long as possible and try to
make it really rude for people to talk
over you by having like a higher energy
level and always ending your sentences
with a conjunction so that every time
you take a breath you say something like
that
oh my god i'm so bad at that are you a
jordan peterson fan i'm not really a
jordan peterson fan um he did this one
thing where he was like i'm doing i'm
doing a lecture
i'm doing a lecture series
on uh how to live like with the bible
like how the bible tells us how to live
or like how it
predicts things in the future and it's
like why are you using the bible
um
why don't you just use any other book
like
i mean i'm sure the bible is
you know
important to a lot of people but i want
to say it's really a great self-help
book or like
it's just old and like old people had
some wisdoms that we can tap into but i
feel like in a book that far away the
the the impact is very
uh limited uh and i think just the fact
that uh
it has a lot of significance and like
traditional
uh backing
i think that uh
it it uh helps a lot more people than it
really should on its own merit
um but i guess like there's some good
stuff in there like dust saith the lord
uh
parable of the
two fish and the loaves the bread
but yeah i'm not a big fan of um
jordan peterson because he's just like
trying to defend the way things are
right now
and
i think that we need to
not do things the way we're doing right
now and how we did it in the 1776's
i think that maybe we should have like a
continually updating system of governing
people instead of just like sticking to
one thing
really really good
um i think it's better to evolve and
you know advance
government
this the science of government
um
then to uh
be really faithful and loyal to the way
things were when it first started
in honor of these dead people
all that no one no one is alive to be
honored by that
they're dead
um
but uh yeah i mean i i think it's like a
preservation of power thing the way that
power
sits right now
and how they arranged it when they first
[ __ ]
flew over on the mayflower floated on
over
i think they're just like this is the
way we want it
we like the way things are now
and we don't want to change the
hierarchy like we want to keep it the
way it is we don't want any
upsetting of the balance
and we're gonna try to keep it that way
for as long as possible
um and i think he's just like a guy
that's just like i want to keep things
the way they are i want power to be
where it is right now it's a good place
we just have to hold on and try a little
harder
um
i think it's i mean
how do you not see like a guy a straight
white guy
advocating for a system that
is advantageous to straight white guys
and be like i think like that's your
self-interest like that's of course
that's what you want
like obviously but yeah i mean what
about everyone else
um but i think that he is a very good
uh at thinking about a lot of different
other things
i think he's good at um
making points and uh being a succinct or
not succinct
i heard he went a lot of tangents on the
podcast to jre today
but um
he uh he's really good at like making a
point and like emotionally delivering a
point and like putting words to ideas
how do you feel about guns like everyone
should everyone have a gun in case the
government does fail
um
everyone should have a gun
oh yeah
when i was on ben's ass
how do you feel about guns like
should everyone have a gun in case the
government does fail
um
if the government does fail
a gun would help
but instead of everyone buying a gun why
don't we make sure the government
doesn't fail if we're going to do
anything if i could like force anyone to
do everything
um
don't drink the kool-aid hans there's
much more to the story
what are we gonna do without men
um
i don't know probably
the same thing that we do on average as
a human race both male and female just
without any of the highs in the extremes
lows
um
i uh i think guns are cool
i think it's cool to live in a world
where you can have ultimate power
um
and i think it's good to
be able to [ __ ] other people up in case
they step on your turf
and make sure that they don't walk again
i think that's all cool
um
i think it's a good
uh
way to say hey we trust you
here's the power to kill people don't
use it unless you have to
um i think that's a cool idea that we
live in a country that's like
all about the individual and
not really about the whole group
and
you can come here and accentuate your
individualness
i mean everyone having a gun as well is
keeping the government from descending
into tyranny
um so every country that bans gun is now
a tyrannical government
i mean all of europe
pretty much bans guns eastern asia
bans guns oceania
i would say that
america is a very rich country
i would say that
maybe
european countries and east asian
countries are
more stable governments that
actually take care of their people
better
and i think tyranny is like a small
group of people
withholding resources from everyone else
uh
and the people suffering because of that
so i mean we have guns and we don't do
[ __ ] with them we just [ __ ]
play around with them and then let
walmart [ __ ] pave over our [ __ ]
homes
so what use is a gun if you're too
stupid to know how to use it and to not
understand the problem
i mean uh we got walmart we got like
purdue pharmaceutical
selling opioids we have guns they sold
drugs right to our face and got us
addicted and
i mean it doesn't matter if you have a
gun if your mind is compromised and
addicted
um but yeah i mean opioids um
corporations have [ __ ] over america in
terms of like cities
layouts and how like they wanted
everything to be about cars so they
destroyed public transit
and they made highways giant highways
going everywhere so that you would need
a car
to get around and plus white people
didn't want to live with black people so
they started moving to the suburbs and
needed a way to get in and out quickly
and so it made it impossible to navigate
your city if you didn't own a car which
is a barrier to entry it's uh
you know
ten thousand dollars
plus gas plus mechanic b fees
um so we let uh corporations like car
companies [ __ ] us over even though we
had guns
it's like uh
and we we settled for a uh labor uh you
know rights that weren't that very good
um we we have less labor labor rights
than most other european or east asian
countries
and we don't have health care
we have guns and we didn't do anything
about that like
guns are just like a tool or like a prop
or like a toy
like
what really affects change is like
organizing politics
um
um bargaining
and uh you know
putting concessions or taking
concessions or something and like apart
like you know doing [ __ ]
um
yeah so it's like uh guns
don't really help us so we just need to
uh actually do [ __ ]
uh we need to [ __ ] you know use our
guns or probably our voices and change
the society we live in
to make it better for us the people
not just a small group of billionaires
but uh yeah i mean guns are great we
should all get guns but we should also
like [ __ ]
use our power let's use our real power
and it's not to kill each other our real
power is to work and produce and make
awesome [ __ ]
and then we can withhold that laborer
and we can actually get the resources
that we work for we can have more money
less time working
more time inventing [ __ ] more time doing
things you actually want to do
and then making the world a better place
because maybe uh you know you're not
good at woodworking now but then you're
going to come up with a design in the
future that's going to save up people a
lot of wood or
it's going to be awesome
the world's going to be a better place
because no there's a new type of chair
crappy music videos you know maybe they
can speak to someone and inspire them to
invent something
um but yeah i mean guns are great i just
wish that we used all our other powers
too
um face tattoos i mean i feel like the
mumble wrap type [ __ ] is just like our
slide into
our subconscious because our conscious
mind is too fraught with troubles and
sadness
so we're like oh no look at the world
the world is so sad um
i don't want to be awake and aware i'd
rather be like
and
not really paying attention
and
kind of
uh nodding off and
not participating
um but yeah everything is bad life sucks
the world is terrible
um
i think that uh it's crazy that uh
you know i went to new york recently
new york is cool
[Music]
new york has a lot of
people in it
[Music]
i think that
new york was a cool city
um
i think that um
new york there was a fun time there
uh the first night i arrived
i had a show at the stand i went to the
stand
uh there was derek gaines i went up last
i went up dead last which is not a great
spot but i went up there i did all right
a lot of other people
did a lot better and uh it kind of made
me insecure
but it was a good time
the audience was great i had it all
right set i had a good time
and then uh
then i went home and then i recorded a
podcast with misha shakur
i stayed at his house i left my
toothbrush there in my retainer
and then uh on the last day we filmed a
little thing where we walked around
times square and we tried to interview
people and i would be like hey
where are you from
and then they would like walk away so i
got like a lot of videos of people just
like walking away
and being sad mark normand was on the
show
um
yeah i mean i did a show at brooklyn
comedy club
it was a cool little venue i loved it
um
yeah i had a good set there that was
probably my favorite set of this of the
trip
i think it said at williams show in uh
jeffersonville pennsylvania right
outside
philadelphia that was fun uh
jeffersonville was great
uh it was like a club it's a golf club
and uh
it's a giant room they got a bar on the
far side they have like a fake wall
and there were like 300 people 200
people
and it's like a great big like uh like
it was like a bar mitzvah almost feeling
and it's just like a banquet hall and
it's like a lot of white people and nice
chairs looking at you
and did comedy in front of them they
were great they were a great audience
they laughed they were easy to laugh
um
[Music]
it was fun and william did great ryan
joseph did great
um
no person alive in the u.s has denied
medical treatment if necessary that is a
fact
okay
um well i can show you a couple news
stories where that definitely happened
like a kid that couldn't afford diabetes
medication insulin
uh so he died
and uh
it's just like it's not gonna happen as
much we still live in a modern society
but it's gonna happen more in america
than most other countries
um but yeah i mean
it's like we have a health care system
that we don't
care about where we purposely are like
we're not gonna [ __ ]
make sure it's good
so people are gonna die
like why would they not die you did no
work to make sure that they wouldn't die
it's like
not doing your homework and then being
like why would i get a bad grade you
didn't do any of the work necessary to
make sure people don't die
uh you clearly were like i'm not gonna
give a [ __ ] about this i'm gonna spend
the least amount of
money on health care
and then people will figure it out
why we would have the the
health care system that produces the
most deaths we did the least amount of
work to make sure we have a good health
care system
we purposely prevent ourselves from
fixing our health care system
um so more people are going to die
unnecessarily and we're that's just the
choice we made
um but yeah i mean
um
but yeah i mean
i think that uh healthcare is pretty
cool
i think it'd be cool if we lived in a
world where you show up and then we just
take care of you give you the best body
we can just feed you just gives you a
lot of [ __ ]
um
and then you're an adult you know a lot
you did exactly what you want to do in
life you're happy you're emotionally
satisfied and you're also
uh intellect until intelligent
and then you go out into the world and
you do awesome [ __ ] like like a [ __ ]
you know
world of tomorrow or like you know
like that one with george clooney
tomorrowland
uh it's just like an awesome world and
if you show up we [ __ ] take care of
you and then we hope you do your best
and give you all the tools necessary to
do the best
i think that's very possible
i think that would be a better society
to live in than one that deprives you of
resources to get you to work harder and
makes you grow up in the ghetto and poor
and sad and lonely it's like well if you
want to get out of this here's a ball
get really good at this
um
uh yeah but i think it's uh cool that a
lot of people want to come to america
and it's like a cool thing to be in
america
and it's like where the world happens
everywhere else it's like not really
you're just like the side characters
like
you're not even the main characters of
the time that you're in who knows that
the time that you're in is going to be
worthy but if it is it's going to be
stuff that happens in america and it's
like if you're not even in the right
country
then you definitely don't stand a good
chance of
making it into the history books and
being
immortal
so
if you're not in america you're [ __ ]
you're a loser
just kidding
um yeah i mean american exceptionalism
like we destroy every
country with uh coups and uh
then their art form suffers and we flood
their market with our
shitty movies and art
and then they can't develop their own
scene and then we're like oh look we're
dominating the world we're keeping them
back and our shitty art will not
not be remembered because whatever
um yeah hopefully
we don't ruin our immortality and our
contribution to
time
and our species by trying to defeat each
other
in the present
instead of like trying to make something
awesome that people will respect in the
future we're just trying to beat each
other and trying to like steal from each
other so that we can
shout out our voice into eternity
uh which happens to be a bleeding goat's
cry
because we are uh
we don't deserve
we don't make good art because we didn't
uh get it correctly we cheated and we
fought and we
uh hurt other people and then we make
art and then it's like whatever because
we were trying to uh win on a very small
uh scale
instead of like the larger scale and
then um
uh and then
it turns out like even if you win in
that realm
uh in the short term like you can still
lose overall
um but yeah i mean i wish that we had a
better
i wish we had a better society so we can
make better art um i don't think that um
our society the way that we think is
very
uh
very healthy i think that where there's
a lot of like uh aggression and violence
and
uh might is right mentality and bullying
that uh
is uh the norm in our society and then
we make art that's just like derivative
and shitty just like the base level that
all these bullies and
evil people can relate to
instead of something more nuanced and
complex because half of us are
destroying the rainforest or
okay with that happening
and minorities dying in the street
so we have to make
movies that are just like good is good
bad is evil
look this good guy he has cool shirt
look at his cool
outfit
he's gonna fight bad guy and bad guy's
winning oh but then good guy wins yay
uh that's the kind of stories that
we that's the kind of stories that we
tell because
we're stupid
but yeah i mean i i think that's good
that uh we create good art too
last good movie
downfall
a german movie
um i'm sure there was a good movie
recently
inception
etc
transformers
captain marvel
whatever
i don't think those are good movies
um but yeah i mean
we do did make citizen kane and
gone with the wind
but yeah i just uh
i mean i have nothing to compare it to
so maybe i'm just like just being
negative and being like oh the world
that i happen to be in sucks it's not my
fault but
i find a lot of solace in blaming
the correct things and not torturing
myself for my imperfections when there's
nothing i can do to fix it because it's
not
really uh
not really something that i can fix
all the time
sometimes it is
the force larger than ourselves that is
broken and so if you can just admit it
and like excise it like a surgeon and
find out exactly where
your faults are and where
everyone else's faults are then
you don't torture yourself and get
depressed because you feel sad for no
reason because you know the reason why
you feel sad
and you know what uh
what you uh
what you need to work on
which is a never-ending task
uh but yeah i mean it's uh
it's also fun to
you know like what are the chances that
the society that you're born in is gonna
be perfect i mean it's some of it's not
going to be great
so to just be like everything is my
fault and i need to work really hard as
a mentality of people in a broken system
[Music]
i think that's how the broken system
continues because then people don't
actually address their root issues they
just [ __ ] torture themselves and
go crazy trying to fix something that
isn't broken
i mean like a lot of like strippers or
like a lot of like people who are strung
out and in a motel in uh detroit or like
lansing like i don't think that they're
that they are uh
that they're weak
i think that they were put in a
situation where like 70 of people are
gonna fall
and uh
like what are you gonna do if you're in
that situation
um and i think that uh
to uh
to make it out is good and we should
motivate people to get out of that
situation
but if you really cared about that
that uh the person you would make sure
that they were never in that position to
begin with and to
provide them a place to live where
they have a higher success rate the more
the higher the success rate the better
and i think that we don't do that
because we don't care and we want to
preserve
the way power is right now we're like
these people know what they're doing i
want them to lead us
don't give anything to anyone else just
keep it the way it is because things are
going fine right now and
these people are doing a great job
that can be perfect as you make it why
are you blaming society because society
needs to be constantly
uh improved and bettered and if you
don't better it then it's going to get
worser and if it gets worser
then people are going to be sadder
so it helps to improve society society
is great to improve
[Music]
hey hans i'm from georgia and i know you
went to georgia tech right oh you miss
georgia
i i do miss georgia what a great state
uh they have a lot of uh large highways
which are annoying um
they uh used the texas
uh handbook and how to build a highway
and just built like a [ __ ] seven-lane
monstrosity right through the city
center i used to live uh
i used to live uh on in the north avenue
apartments which looked directly over
the highway
and for like six months they blocked my
window with plywood because they were
doing construction and it was
hard to live without windows you don't
realize it but windows are great
and when they block it out it's really
really sad
but yeah
uh georgia's great
i mean i don't really like a lot of
the way that american cities are
designed
atlanta is great the people are great
they're warm and friendly they have good
food southern [ __ ]
[Music]
um
yeah i mean georgia's fun i like georgia
i'm having a good time
uh
i love good southern accent okay girl
southern beach a lot of pretty girls um
a lot of uh
there's a beautiful campus
it's just like people are nice there
it's just nice
um people are trustworthy and kind and
you know
they're doing their best and they mean
well and
it was just a good place to be
um
how's the dating show going the dating
show is going good i'm just gonna keep
doing it
it's a fun thing to do i don't really
have to prepare at all
um
and it's a good time
uh i think
i hope to get better at it
um
i think there are some really high highs
on that show
i just want to keep doing it i think uh
the more i do it the better it'll get
there's been a good crowd the last
couple times i think it's increasing in
uh
audience
and i think that uh if i keep doing it
it'll be fun
and i want to have a good time doing it
um
and
it's fun to talk to people it's fun to
like go for the joke and like express
yourself through jokes and say what you
want to say
and uh offer your perspective and
observations in a humorous way and have
it be received well
and
you know just like work on that muscle
and just learn how to talk to people can
you give some insight on what it's like
in the green room before kill tony that
is if you have a green room setting in
the first place
another goat i definitely have green
room setting
um
the green room is very cool um
it's
a great dynamic if you haven't been in a
green room uh you're not gonna know what
it's like there's a very clear hierarchy
and a power dynamic going on
um there it's all about positivity
um tony wants to be in a good mood uh i
think that um
everyone's trying to keep the mood
positive and no one's trying to drag it
down
uh no one is demanding more attention
than they deserve everyone knows their
place
and everyone is trying to do their part
uh
um
and uh
it's just a good vibe it's uh very uh
very uh structured and uh very safe and
uh
it's uh
the social hierarchies and the way that
we communicate is uh very very
interesting and i think that that's why
our brains are so complex and uh
you're just constantly like figuring out
where you stand and like what you can
get away with saying and trying to make
the mood positive and like there's no
negative
people that are just trying to make it
shitty
for because they're insecure they're sad
or something
so it's just good it's just cool
um yeah
so basically it's like a job it's like a
job where you can say [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
and
[ __ ]
so yeah it's just like your job
um but yeah there's like a more fun
atmosphere there's not like a weird sort
of like
oh we can't have that emotion it's very
emotionally intelligent
uh and very emotionally high highs and
low lows
um it's just
it's just a different uh
yeah i don't know what i was saying
it's not a job
it's fun it's a good time
it's uh
it's interesting
have i grown a pair yet
have you grown a pair
zachary bennett
what's your f what's your youtube page
look like
um
hello the blue guy banned someone for
having a reasonable disagreement
um well i hope the ban was worthy i uh
i wasn't a part of the
decision making process
um
i i've been meeting a lot of people
after the show that's fun
people are generally nice unless they're
telling you you smell like ramen
um
oh my god
how much dollar we got hans i have like
almost 20k now
i'm pretty close to 20k
which is the first time in my life that
i've hit 20k so that's a good thing
i'm just saving it up i'm living in this
place for free
i get a lot of free food
i barely spend many money i mean i'm
getting a lot of money from my shirts
and my stickers i should go sell them
more
[Music]
would you do man on the street style
interviews you would def kill it i have
done it i should do it more
it's just like
when you're opening yourself up to
people
on the street
it's uh
it's not always fun
and uh
i don't uh really know if i want to
expose myself like that
but generally it's a good thing
and it can be fun
i um
i just yeah i mean i'll do it fine
no i uh i love doing it
um
[Music]
i wish i could get to texas to see y'all
live
love you hans
yeah i mean
tickets are pretty cheap i flew to new
york for 30 bucks
it could have been 60 round trip
um but uh yeah money is great i love
having the money
i love uh relaxing sort of and being
able to go anywhere i want and do
anything i feel like doing and
not being so stressed out when i lose
[ __ ] because i can just buy another
thing
but yeah i mean
i think it's uh great to do a lot of
different things
let's see
so
i think that
we should um
try to
have a
time where we
all like
go vote for the correct things
um
apparently a road rager shot two
motorists last night at 290 and william
cannon in austin you all be careful out
there says this reddit guy
um
i
i love
[Music]
austin austin's a good city
i think that uh
we could uh
really fix
a lot of problems and stuff
so dan crenshaw um
i think that
he likes
the way things are for obvious reasons
and he wants to keep it that way
um
i think that
a lot of the solutions for society's
woes
wouldn't actually work
um
and i think that uh
he's uh
he's a very good talker
he's good at
talking uh
you need to have a kid and then question
what you have to offer to the world
i mean
ricky gervais doesn't have children and
he's still
making afterlife
which i uh
heard mixed reviews about
i mean having kids is a great way to
think about things but i don't i don't
think it's the only way
i think there's lots of different ways
to think about
things um
[Music]
i i would love to have kids i think it's
a great biological trick to play on
yourself
and it gets you a lot of
insight into life and stuff
um but i think it's kind of weird to
have a kid for self-improvement and as
an exercise and just to like improve
your life
um i would like to do it for less
selfish reasons
um and i would love to do it
soonish
um i mean i do have 20k so i could
probably keep a baby alive for like two
years
i have no idea
um but yeah i mean once you have a baby
you get entered into the system they can
[ __ ] with you then
they can hold your baby hostage
um
and uh i live in a van
i would love to have a kid in a van i
think it's very possible i think that if
you get caught with a kid in a van it's
probably not great
i think people try to [ __ ] with you then
um
i uh i think that's kind of [ __ ] up
because just because you live in a van
doesn't mean it's a shitty van
uh or that your baby's in any danger
like there was a dad who was camping
with his children and someone called the
cops on him
uh
because they're like i don't think they
have heat in there
and uh like when you have kids just
opens you up to like just [ __ ]
[ __ ] get [ __ ] with
um but yeah i mean uh
can i raise a child in a van
i mean if i had to if it was like the
road
obviously it'd be better in a house so
then i'd have to get that
i'd have to pay like however much a
month it would take a lot of time away
from comedy so i wouldn't be able to
work as much
so yeah i mean i don't know if that's
the right move right now
but uh yeah i mean
i think that if you have a nice van you
should be allowed to have a baby yeah
you're at a higher risk for the baby
dying than if you lived at home
just because like you might run over it
or like might fly out the window
it's just like less
less safe but i mean
if you're doing that like what about
someone who's living uh
you know like with a lower
um
salary or like living in the ghetto or
like
you know
in between houses or something
it's like
if if it's the
like uh the lifespan of the baby or like
the infant mortality rate that you're
worried about then put it in the
calculator and be like oh we did the
math and it turns out van lifers have a
two percent chance of killing their
babies
uh but some this other woman
who is like
i don't know like
poor and
stupid and
her iq is really low and she's like
not really taking care of herself her
baby has a three percent chance that it
won't survive so we're going to nuke
this person's baby
and then this other person's baby the
van lifers baby we're gonna let it grow
like do the math figure it out if it's
actually that dangerous don't just be
like it just looks wrong that's not
where you're supposed to have a baby
like give me give me the numbers
uh i don't want to just hear people be
like well what did you expect
you had raised a kid in a van
but uh and then but then like there's a
bunch of reasons babies die and when it
dies in a home you're like well you know
you can never really predict these
things and sometimes it happens
i'd rather not rely on just like village
gossip although village gossip can be a
helpful tool to
maybe keep your eye out on the data that
comes in i think that you know you know
i'll plug in the numbers and figure out
how likely it is that this baby will die
and
make a
educated guess instead of just going by
how it looks like some vans are really
nice and
they're going to be outdoors like are we
gonna prescribe that every baby has to
live in a house and
uh
like have to drive everywhere and have
to like live in a suburb that's a food
desert and they have to live this life
where their mom has to take them
everywhere they go
and
and then um
and then they can't walk anywhere and
then if they do walk alone the cops the
cops get called and everyone every child
has to live this certain life
um
or are you gonna let them live in a van
and like go surfing every day and like
visit different national parks
and like just live a different lifestyle
we all have to live this lifestyle that
doesn't seem like the land of the free
and living in a van doesn't necessarily
mean it's dangerous
if you have all the safety equipment
and you take care of your baby you
should be able to live in a van or a
motorhome or an rv
will you ever stop saying the word [ __ ]
hans
will you
i mean you typed it out now that's on
the government's watch list
[ __ ] i don't think it has the uh
cultural impact that the word n-word
does i almost said it
um
or the [ __ ] word or the [ __ ] word so
i think it's cool like not a lot of
people say it but if you do say it in
like a heightened situation then the
impact is the same as the n-word
so it's just like a matter of uh context
but [ __ ] i think is uh
i think that
[Music]
it is a word to describe asians and it's
used in very
negative connotations a lot of times so
maybe people have a negative association
with that word
um but i try not to avoid emotions or
fear or like unpleasant situations
like uh yeah i mean
i don't try to like just not think of
asians as like sometimes in the worst
possible light i think uh
sometimes some asians are seen in that
light and uh
yeah i mean i obviously try not to uh
associate as asians negatively with
anything but
i think that because i actually
respect the culture that
to me saying [ __ ] doesn't take anything
away from asian culture which i think is
superior to american culture
in many ways
i guess i'm korean american i do see the
advantages of the american culture but
yeah [ __ ] i think um
i think it's better to
um
say it ironically and have like a
distanced relationship with that word
than to never say it and have like this
forbidden
uh you know like
a
legal sort of like feeling towards a
word and then when it gets said then it
destroys your whole world because you
never said it and someone else
is the first one to say it
so i think it's better that uh
we internalize
the [ __ ]
now you definitely should internalize
the [ __ ] and
the worst ways of seeing our race
but
i think that it's uh good to have that
battle
to be like
oh i'm feeling negatively towards asian
people and like what that means and
i uh i gotta remember the positive parts
and i think that if you do that a lot
then you can have a positive feeling
towards a race
uh better than if you just avoid all
negative implic and negative stereotypes
about that race
um
yeah
i think it's a much more deeper
respect and love for the race
to uh
to be able to
uh say [ __ ] and like
understand um
what people mean by that word and then
to also have respect for it than to just
have blind respect and not
uh see the negative side of being asian
but only the positive and not have a
realistic view of being asian
what will the white people think of
affirmative action ending when the
colleges are all asian
yeah i mean if it's purely merit-based
maybe like everyone's going to be asian
in colleges
i think that it's a socio-economic thing
so i think we need to get
white people and black people and white
people to be richer
then i think that they'll get higher sat
scores
um
but that takes a lot more money and
there's a more delayed response
so for a while asians are gonna
be dominating ivy leagues and we're just
gonna be all over the place
um
but uh you know
it's gonna be fine
you know someone has to do that [ __ ]
i mean
why do you want not want to reward
people for working hard you want to be
like yeah you work too hard we we're
going to take some of this away
what's your take on son
i don't know how that is
it's not me oh the soccer player he's
the one that like does something with
his hands
um i think he's great i think he shows
oh yeah he does a little camera thing or
the tv thing with his hands
i think he's a great soccer player
and he expresses himself very well
he uh is korean he shows off that
koreans can uh
uh you know be athletically competitive
and that um
the the
culture of korean-ness
uh is able to produce awesome athletes
and that
he's a great uh he's great at expressing
himself in that way
i just think sports is pretty limited
all you can really say is
try really hard and shoot really fast
and work really hard again
uh it's like it's a pretty limited um
i mean uh spectrum of uh output that you
can
put out there
and do it even if it's hard
i mean um
i think sports is great
i think it's good to do i think it makes
an awesome person like being a warrior
does
um
but yeah i mean i think that um
it's better to like actually say stuff
and use your words
which you could do after you do soccer
but like why don't you just do it right
away but there should be someone that
does soccer i just wish that like the
people that did soccer then went on to
do other stuff that was actually like
useful
uh but yeah it's cool to watch the
highlight reels and to feel the
excitement that comes from it
um
yeah i mean i love soccer i don't mean
to talk [ __ ] about athletes
i just wish that uh we had a
different way of valuing stuff
um
i think athletes are important
but not that important
my question is are you also an excellent
multitasker
um i try not to
i can sing some korean songs
um
yeah i mean
i uh i want to make like a movie about
how like there's so many marvel movies
and then just like
you know like someone that's like sick
of it and like how it's everywhere and
then like
i don't know i don't know what i want to
do
so yeah i mean kill tony yesterday went
pretty good
i had a good time i loved the interview
part
um
i think that the set went all right i
wish i did better i kind of had some new
jokes that i wanted to try but then i
went with an old joke instead
and i kind of regret it i kind of wish i
did like my artistically peer set but
that's the good thing about being a
regular is that i have all these
opportunities to try
and do different things and i wish um
yeah maybe i'll speak s stick more with
my gut and do things that i like to do
[Music]
um but yeah kill tony was fun i watched
some of that episode i skipped out on a
lot of it i wish i could have watched
but there's so much [ __ ] happening
in that room
um i think
tony is so much fun
i can't wait for it and there's a party
and i just get to meet a bunch of people
and like there's a lot of positive
emotions a lot of people say nice things
to me
um and there's like uh
everyone like seems to like me
and uh that's like the place where like
i get the most positive feedback and
emotion so it's
pretty fun for
me
um
[Music]
and it's sort of like i'm a celebrity
there so
i try to take advantage of that
um
[Music]
i have a good time
um
then after the show you know some people
are mean some people are nice
um but yeah i mean i try to get to know
people
because i am interested in people
right i think so
but yeah i mean uh it's fun to just
socialize and stuff like that but
hopefully you know more things can
happen than just socializing maybe
sexualizing
they say the hottest part of the flame
is at the tip
a lot of people try to light it down
here
but
this is actually the hottest part
because heat rises i guess
but yeah i mean um kill tony is such a
great experience for me i'm really glad
that i get to do it
i um
i think i was supposed to
well i wasn't supposed to do [ __ ] i was
hoping that i would get to open for
rogan today but it doesn't look like
it's happening
um
which is fine i guess
yeah i mean i i don't want to be
demanding but i really really enjoy
doing it and i also don't want to lose
that either
so maybe it's good to be jealous
but maybe not
um
so chrissy is calling
let me let me answer on the podcast
what's up you're on the podcast
um i just wanted to say like are we good
yeah
okay
should i just talk about it later then
where are you
at the house
uh how long doing your house
yep i thought that maybe you'd be
waiting to go on stage at eight o'clock
or something like that yeah it could
have been it usually starts at 8 30 so
this would have been a fine time to call
but yeah joe
joe didn't call me um
yeah i mean uh
why didn't you give me a ride
oh you mean joe rogan did they call you
yeah
i mean is it really that big a deal to
give me a ride from the downtown to like
15 minutes north
does he call you and talk on the phone
verbally
not all the time he did it once usually
tony texts me sometimes joe texts me
yeah
that's usually what it would do yeah
does he sound like his podcast he's like
oh i don't even know what he would sound
like hey hans
uh yeah that's cool yeah
uh so uh why didn't you want to give me
a ride to
my apartment i was only just telling you
i didn't even i didn't even say like
oh my god [ __ ] you like absolutely not i
didn't even say that i just said like
hey
i'm
you know that those are both too far
away locations and i'm like really
struggling so i don't know about that
well it's just your typical attitude of
like
oh my god i have to do things for you
now don't you think that i'm more
important than you it's just like you're
not willing to do anything for anyone
else
are you serious do you think that about
me
i do know i uh
cleaned a little bit
really
yeah i'm about to
um
so uh did you do the laundry
yeah i did my laundry did you do my
laundry
it didn't like those clothes i started
to realize that maybe that's what why
why they were in there but i didn't know
because i think you don't smell i guess
like it didn't smell like if they were
my clothes you would have smelled them
like from six feet away
you know
yeah
dirty clothes
sorry that i'm available
telling you that i mean it's like
it's tough stuff right now and like you
know that would be a big deal to like
drive all over the place and stuff
so i was just telling you that but then
and i asked sam and he said
everything was fine like he was like no
i'm i'm going to be near the airport and
like it's going to be good
you know yeah
so it's not easy
and i feel like you got mad and when you
sent me that last angry text i was like
in kind of a bad place to get that text
so
i got it
but
apparently
you're
like struggling you're like struggling
right like you can't go to the doctor
dude i mean the
my mane i don't know if you remember
when i told you like wow i found a
stable
sugar daddy he's like so perfect or
whatever like i told you that
he last night was supposed to meet with
me after kill tony and he like ghosted
me
you know and like that's something that
kind of keeps happening with him which
is basically yeah he's trying to
he doesn't give he doesn't like me i
guess
that's so bad and he hasn't paid me at
all like i've only gotten 200 since i
got here and that just goes immediately
into like
you do uber eats
yeah i just like you know it's like a
yearly resolution i want to stop
you know spinning
all of my you know
it's a crazy trade for like a whole hour
of your time
[Music]
yeah you know
your time for like a little bit of money
yeah but like i'm working on it like
this guy here is about to come home and
like from for after a week away
and i'm gonna like show him my bank
like notice
at some point okay you got props
what you got a prop you got you should
do a powerpoint presentation
i'm just gonna be like damn look at this
like it's gonna be like my bank um
somebody else was telling me that i
should file for bankruptcy like that
it's not even a big deal
um
to just file for bankruptcy they were
like it's completely easy and
i guess you really don't have debt
nope
my parents paid for my college
you what
yeah well um i'll uh see you around
i um are you mad though like
i said hi to you yesterday and you like
um
looked at me like you were mad a little
bit
yeah i was a little mad at you
are you still mad
i would give you right like especially
if my gas tank especially if i like was
able to
have money for gas i would give you
rides like
you know
i could easily i guess i'm really
sensitive
what
i guess i was really sensitive or
something
yeah i mean you were in new york it's
cold
maybe you were working hard like walking
around
yeah i mean um
i just uh it's difficult to um
you know hear like you're also on my
podcast no i'm just kidding i'm sorry
i'm sorry
yeah
yeah but uh
yeah i mean i'll uh i'll see you later
and i'm sure that uh
we'll we'll see each other soon
okay
bye bye
good night
yeah i mean uh i maybe shouldn't have
done that
but uh
i uh i guess i got my feelings hurt
because she wouldn't come pick me up and
it was just like
oh my god what it's just like
she immediately made it like analytical
like what would i what am i getting out
of this
and like it's like that's just not a
good like mindset that i want to like
think about my friends and
uh i don't want her to or to my for my
the people around me or my friends to be
like
um
i wanted to be like you know oh no it's
like a thing
it's like uh
it's like are we doing math constantly
and like it's just like
it put a it put it like kind of like
made me think about the relationship
that we have in a different way
and it just made me feel like gross and
like cheated and
um
yeah i mean
i guess like
also there's like a lot of uh
a lot of uh my friends tell me like
that i should be more careful or
something
so yeah i mean um
i feel like
i feel like uh it's just
it was just a bad situation for a
friendship and i think like
christy's very honest
and stuff so she uh sometimes
um
i i've never uh so it's like she's she's
just like uh sometimes
things come up
when dealing with christy that wouldn't
with other people but you know whatever
um
i um
yeah i mean i uh
i think that christy is a very
interesting person and uh she's very um
very honest and uh
sometimes that's refreshing
i feel like she had almost no gas and no
money to get more than she should have
openly said that to you and wish the
ball would would have been in your court
office money or not get the ride i agree
with you linda the goat
uh but i just thought it'd be
interesting to bring it up just because
it's like something that happens not
just with christy and me but with a lot
of different people
and um
i'm gonna try to handle it correctly and
i could use like an outside perspective
and use
um
[Music]
the presence of an outside perspective
to maybe gain perspective on what's
happening and maybe not get too bent out
of shape about it
um
uh
[Music]
i think that uh
i think it's great to
get in a lot of different situations and
learn how to do things
differently
um
i think it's uh
i think it's interesting
um i'm not going out tonight apparently
um
um i might be getting a little horny
i am texting women
but um yeah i mean i love uh
i love different things that happen with
uh
friendships
um
i think that uh
i think it's good to uh
talk to people and stuff
i
i think that
some things on the news ukraine
and russia and america and
we're like don't [ __ ] invade ukraine
and then america is like we're going to
invade you if you invade ukraine
people are like trump
if trump was in office this would never
happen
yeah because we all know how
much trump was respected
um there's a reason why
russian people and meme bots were trying
to get trump elected because that
destabilizes america
like trump having been in office for
four years and our botched response to
coronavirus puts us not in a great
position
um
to deal with this uh we have lost a lot
of credibility and people aren't going
to listen to us when we talk
so now our only option is violence
or now the option is lessened for
negotiation politics
um yeah i mean if trump was in office
uh
what is trump gonna do that biden isn't
also willing to do biden is willing to
do every warmongering thing
that trump would have done
um
i
i don't see trump as being an advantage
in this situation or in any situation
it's surprising that you have to say
that but yeah i mean trump is not a good
president he doesn't uh do good [ __ ]
he's not good at the job
and yeah i mean
he's not a good president he's not a
good person um
yeah i mean uh ukraine it's like
they're gonna invade ukraine and
obviously we hate that
we don't want that
um
i think that um
[Music]
we should try to avoid war
i don't know if that's
what everyone's thinking
i think that uh we're ruled by idiots
and cretans and
morons and animals and they want battle
they want to fight
so that's what we're gonna get
uh vladimir putin is like a mobster he's
like treating the world like a ghetto
he's like got a track suit on he's like
shaking down businesses
and um
america is like trump like an orangutan
or like a
gorilla just beating its chest
uh trump energy and biden is just like
uh george bush like
mass digression
uh
behind like bureaucracy and old white
men in suits is like bloodthirsty and
like
like a chimp or like a gorilla
banging on his chest
and
[Music]
i just think that we are if we were in
high school we're ruled by the
football players and the jocks
instead of the nerds and the theater
kids and the chess master chess club
and i think that if the
drama drama club was in charge the
people that are more intellectual
that the world would be a better place
but
there's a disadvantage to being a
theater kid and it's that you are
lacking in the ability to commit
violence and if violence is on the table
then uh
the more violent people are selected for
in whatever
uh game that you're playing
so we just need to like dial down the
temperature on violence and not make
violence such an advantageous thing to
utilize and then the world will be a
better place
um
then um
we could talk this out and be like what
do you really want with ukraine what do
we want with ukraine what do we all
really want
and we should just like talk to each
other and figure out what
we're doing and not try to kill each
other and starve each other economically
um
aren't all white men in suits giving you
the opportunity to do comedy
they're also preventing
a lot of people from doing comedy
they set the numbers up so that only a
few people can
obtain the right
[Music]
to do comedy
but yeah i mean i guess they allow
everything but
i mean i live in a van so i don't know
if they allowed me or if i
did it
myself
in flagrant disregard to their norms and
their
traps
um
violence is inherent in humans
so is cooperation
um
i'm buying the russian comrade nft
holder's lives will be spared when putin
invades
you'll have to present a
blockchain
verified
passcode
i think
violence should be avoided
i think it's um
i mean i think it's
america is definitely not chill
if you're a russia you want to be in a
very friendly mood
um
i i think that
[Music]
america is also trying to get ukraine to
join the north atlantic treaty
organization the nato
so that's kind of seen as an aggressive
move
um
[Music]
it's just um
it's um
it's threatening um america after russia
was defeated in the cold war
they were not very friendly to that
country they let it fall into disrepair
and it was clear that it wasn't really
about
freedom or the right thing to do it was
a petty
uh
spiding of russia
and
you know
like [ __ ] them up and like just
they're like we don't care about you we
we didn't want to free you from
communism we wanted to punish you for
trying it
and so
after
they were like okay we'll we'll do what
you want
they weren't treated very well and then
the country fell into the hands of the
mobsters and the crazy people like putin
and um
why would they trust us why we didn't
treat them very well so like they have
no incentive to be nice to us and then
it's like well if we're on our own let's
just get putin and
have him battle the [ __ ] other people
so that
but yeah i mean i i wish that uh after
the cold war we were like okay
you uh you relented you surrendered
here's like
a lot of uh [ __ ] that you're missing out
on and
here's uh well we'll help you along and
really
you know it said that didn't happen they
were just left to fend for themselves
and um
you know maybe that would have been seen
as interference and intervention
uh but uh yeah i mean after years
decades of like [ __ ] with russia for
no reason during the cold war just
because they were trying a new system of
government and we really hated that they
were like advancing past the founding
fathers
we were like
uh they probably don't like us anymore
that much because
we we were really mean to them
putin uh
yeah i mean uh
and then like it all became about like
the oligarchs
and the capitalists and now they're
capitalists and like a small group of
people rule over the country
um
i mean
i'm sure russia's
russia is a good
doing economically like
right right alongside uh
i would say right alongside spain
maybe they have a larger economy than
thailand
i think south korea has a larger economy
than russia
um
i mean uh
during communism they were second place
so
i mean if capitalism so awesome
why is russia
doing worse worse under capitalism
uh if you think russia didn't have subs
off us
u.s waters you are misinformed about the
cold war
why did they have those subs there who
started the aggression were the russians
like america you have too much freedom
we're gonna [ __ ]
put subs right by your waters or was
america like this is dangerous we can't
have this spreading let me
meddle with the elections in greece and
italy to make sure communism doesn't uh
become a democratically accepted thing
let's make sure that even though the
people might want communism that it
never happens
um
and yeah i mean it's like an ideological
thing we didn't want people to
find a new system of government
communism socialism isn't noble because
humanitarian is an advertised virtue
um
well
just because you're advertising it
doesn't mean that you're not doing it
um
i look at it as there were
massive dangers in blood there's
bloodthirsty superpower that
miraculously the u.s managed to neuter
without destroying the planet just
because it wasn't perfect doesn't mean
doesn't mean u.s bad
dangerous bloodthirsty superpower
if you're looking for a bloodthirsty
dangerous superpower i mean america
invaded a bunch of different countries
in south america and latin america and
southeast asia
uh russia
was not that imperialistic america was
way more
they were conquering way more territory
than russia was
so if
we were afraid of
you know a massive dangerous
bloodthirsty superpower why would why
did we become it
um but yeah i mean russia was trying to
get allies like in cuba and um
[Music]
maybe the congo
north korea china
i mean china and russia were never
really great allies
but um
i guess like uh
they were trying to compete with america
like america had great britain they had
france they had germany
west germany anyways
they had uh you know italy and greece
and
spain and all the allies japan and
i guess china they didn't have but they
they had like all of europe allied
against the russians and they had all
the force
in the world that's where all the
richest countries are as western europe
um and the soviet union was just like
you know
off in the off in the hinterlands
um but yeah i mean
russia
and our history with them
i don't think that it was good that uh
we [ __ ] with them so heavily
i uh i think that if we didn't have if
we hadn't started the cold war
that russia at best would have you know
just
sent space rockets into space and
a lot of their war crimes were
in uh defense of of like trying to work
uh work out how to uh battle america i
mean the whole of tomorrow was bad but
it wasn't like on purpose it was like
i guess uh stalin was a little paranoid
of i think it was ukraine
and uh he was was kind of careless with
them and that had dire consequences and
like millions of people died
but uh
i think that uh
i think that that was like a mistake and
like that was like the growing pains of
modernization
and a new system of government
i think that
russia wouldn't have
killed its own people
to an extreme stream degree
um
and i think that like the worst that
they would have done is like maybe had
another famine
um which they avoided after the whole of
the moor
but um
if you're looking for
famine deaths like the great bengal
famine in india is pretty bad
i think a lot more people died in india
under british rule because of uh
profit seeking um
uh resource
distribution
uh they didn't have any reserves so
during like a rough
harvest like a whole shitload of people
starved to death and it happened over
and over again
on like millions hundreds of millions of
uh i think
tens of millions maybe 100 million uh
indian people died because of uh
because of british mismanagement and the
potato famine
um
famines obviously are not ideal and we
should do our best to avoid it
uh but yeah i mean i i don't think that
there was a reason to [ __ ] with russia i
don't think that they had really any
territorial
ambitions
um they were already pretty large ussr
and they were invaded by germany and
they fought back i don't think that they
were a threat to the world
and if they were antagonizing them
probably made it worse
um
i think that uh
it's sad that uh
russia doesn't trust us and we don't
live in a society where we're getting
along
and uh creates bad tension and uh
now they're trying to invade ukraine or
something
i mean how many people are killed in
america by our own people
how many people do we kill through
poverty and neglect
um i think that's a humanitarian crisis
for sure
uh but yeah i mean maybe we just have a
long-term way of doing things like it's
like slower but it's like a drip
and
uh
we don't really take care of our people
russia has been trying to get ukraine
for years
um
i i give pretty good relationship advice
you know like someone is like oh i'm
with this girl and she's just like
talking a lot and stuff
and i'm like oh have you tried talking a
lot yourself you know fight fire with
fire
that's what i like to do i don't really
respect the art form of talking so it's
like if you're doing it then i'll just
do it and
i don't care if i'm boring because
obviously you don't care if you're
boring it's all about like
being able to uh
do as much talking as possible to
trigger the amount of rudeness the other
person is most comfortable displaying
to you and uh just backing off of that
and making it so that it's uncomfortable
to
disapprove and that
i don't know a lot of people don't like
the way that i talk to women
um
i um
i
i don't know i i try to
be nice but like if they're mean to me
then i uh
i don't think it's wrong to respond in
kind
but um obviously that's not the main
focus
uh when i talk to women is to make sure
that i hurt them
as much as they hurt me that's just like
something like a gear that i have that i
try not to tap into in social situations
regardless of man or woman
but um
yeah
i i i mean like if they're talking a lot
i think that's kind of a rude thing to
do
so like then i talk a lot
like uh
um yeah i mean if they're gonna talk why
shouldn't i talk
we're all talking now right like what do
you think you're better than me
um
and uh i can talk
we can all talk
uh but yeah i think that it's important
to um
have an equal exchange and i think if
one person tries to dominate and take up
like 70 80 90 of the conversation time
that's really really [ __ ] up
uh i think that's a super rude thing to
do because
then you don't let the other person
think and then it's just a competition
and it ruins conversation
uh and
and um i think that um
i think that uh
i think it's a not polite thing to do to
talk uh
more than you're wanted to
and i think 50 50 is the norm and if any
if there's a slight fluctuation in that
that's fine
uh but i don't think that uh one person
should be doing all the talking
that's really bad and i think like if
you make it about that and you just
constantly compete with each other to
see who can talk the most then it just
creates a hostile environment
and the quality of the conversation goes
down as force and violence is uh
selected for and i think it's better to
have like a more intellectual
relationship where
um
i think it's better to have like a a
conversation where
like uh you're trying to strive for
equality and if they're stupid then why
are you with them
you shouldn't uh be with someone you're
not willing to share half the
conversation with
um
and i think that um
[Music]
yeah i mean
it should be equal as much as possible
and if someone's just trying to dominate
for the sake of dominating that's really
gross
i think what hans is trying to say is
women should know when men wanted them
to talk and be quiet when it's out of
turn or did i get that wrong
i mean i don't think you have to make
equality about force and
um
and uh
unequalness and listening to one person
over the other i think it's uh it should
be 50 50 and you should listen to the
other person
equally as much as you're talking
um and i think that uh if you are
unaware of what the person opposing you
or not opposing you but the opposite of
you is feeling and what they might want
then what are you doing why are you
talking if it's not to impact the person
in front of you if it's just to hear
yourself talk
then uh you can do it on your own um
or have an outlet that's healthier
but obviously this isn't a woman thing i
mean men like like to talk over people
all the time and it's super especially
american men
and i'm not saying that women are uh
overtalkers although sometimes they are
but um
i'm just saying like american men it's
like a bit about ego it's like i should
get to be the one that talks because i
can physically enforce it
and uh i'm also the most important
smartest funniest person here
and i think that's gross
but yeah i mean this isn't just about
men and women i think
yeah you should be paying attention to
what the other person wants from you and
i don't think that means that you're
just doing whatever the man tells you to
do i think it means that you're
responding to the environment that
you're in instead of doing whatever you
want
um because that requires no discipline
and even a child can do that where they
just say whatever the [ __ ] they want
and uh that's not uh something that
you should do unless it's wanted you
shouldn't force it on people you should
be more aware of people
uh around you and
appreciate them and speak in a way that
they want to hear
um
but uh yeah i mean also you need to
express yourself and not be so asian and
just be shy and quiet and just only say
things
um
whenever you think like the group
approves but also to just like express
yourself and i feel like conversation
and talking is like a diode and everyone
is like
a diode that is like a
uh
it's like a diode that represents
whether the what the what the subunit is
feeling like what each graphic card is
feeling so if like graphic card a feels
happy and sad and then graphic card b
feels nervous and anticipatory so it's
like everyone should like speak like
everyone
each diode should like click off and
some people have more to say some people
have less to say but i think when you
try to like
take more than you're comfortable with
or you think that you are a guy that
talks that needs to take more of the
conversation than is necessary then
i think that um
i think then uh it becomes grading
and
difficult to
stop
um because then you have to be rude to
stop the person being rude which is an
even bigger thing to be rude to someone
rather than talk too much so then it
becomes like you're you're you become
the
[ __ ] um
have you ever tried listening 100 of the
time including what you're saying
i don't know
why you're including what i'm saying
if i'm listening 100 of the time then i
wouldn't be saying anything so i
wouldn't be able to include it
i like it when that um
okay so yeah i mean
um
i mean i everyone has their own
tolerance for rudeness but we all have
the capacity to
observe and pick up cues and figure out
where
each person's rudeness level is i have
obviously been rude to people
and
without knowing or with a flagrant
disregard to the cues they were sending
out and maybe i could do a better job in
the future
i always strive to do a better job and i
wish everyone would too because i don't
think a lot of people are trying i don't
think they're even aware of it but they
can talk too much they're like oh that's
not a thing it's impossible for me to
talk too much so let me just not try at
all
so yeah i mean i just wish that some
people were aware that nobody i'm not
like
except for joe rogan i'm never like oh i
just want to hear this person talk and
talk and talk the only person i do that
for is joe rogan and tony hinchcliffe uh
people that i respect but people just
think that they have that when they
haven't done the work that tony and
schlofer joe rogan have done
and like some people have like a lot to
say
um
and that's fine but it's it seems like a
lot of people just want to be the guy
that takes up a lot of time in the
conversation
but yeah i mean obviously i'm asian i'm
going to say that the asians malfunction
in another way which is where we don't
say anything at all and then we don't
actually say what we want to say and
then we never express ourselves
that's sad
versus when people justify the rudeness
by always being brutally honest in
quotes
yeah i mean that's a cover for a lot of
people they're like i'm not
rude i'm just
speak my mind
well you know a child can do that a
child can observe [ __ ]
it's how you convey it to other people
that matters
if you aren't good at conveying [ __ ]
then your brutal honesty is wasted and
it serves no function because people are
going to ignore you
it does nothing to you it's observations
are the first step and then the second
step is communication and you've only
worked on the first step and haven't
done anything about the second step
but yeah i mean uh obviously i'm talking
about someone specific here
uh truly being honest really honest is
when you ask for permission first
okay so anyways i'm hungry i'm probably
gonna eat soon i might try to do three
more minutes to hit
two hours
yeah let's just do three more minutes
just like i'm exercising and i want to
bust out
a couple more reps
so this is just like exercise for me
like i'm hard at work right now
thinking of something to say just to
fill time so that
i can fill up two hours and feel good
about myself because i hit an arbitrary
number
um
it's weird how
if that second was a little shorter a
little longer how different the world
would be
but for some reason it's the way it is
and
i wonder if the person that invented how
long the second was
was like
this is going to change everything a
second is this
oh my god is so whatever
it's a value listening more than 3. read
somewhere read somewhere where they say
it's an easter philosophy that
and listening more than speaking
yeah i mean it's good if you want to
create like a large agrarian society uh
it's bad if you want to create a lot of
uh
you know like conquerors who are going
to cough on a bunch of native americans
and take over the world
um
um
but also it's like we need the american
individualism to bring out the best in
individuals which is how the the base
unit of humanity is individual and if we
strengthen the base unit then the whole
becomes greater
so we need to also focus on the
individual um
and that's something that i don't think
asian cultures do that well they just
look at the individual as like a
thing to be turned into a math machine
and
like i mean it's it'd be great if we had
a great education system and we knew
exactly how to educate children but um
it's just um
we don't have like a great
way of knowing like what's best for a
kid
and
i think that
i am happy
uh i think
i think that um
if we knew exactly how to train a kid
then it would make sense to educate them
like crazy but now like to make them
learn math and like
you know [ __ ] and like memorize a
bunch of [ __ ] like that's not a
great way to use a human mind and i
think that asians are wasting a lot of
human potential making them into
graphing calculators
instead of making them into something
more uh unique and creative and
uh
yeah i mean it's just deadens the soul
to like do math all day and we need kids
to be out and playing and learning
social things instead of just sitting in
a room
and getting really good at sitting in a
room for eight hours i think that ruins
the body too
uh but yeah i mean we should treat
people better but i mean that's what we
had to do to get out of the [ __ ]
whatever we had to like just be like
everyone get together and [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] get really good at economy
and as soon as economy is good we'll
[ __ ] pull out and gracefully land but
then we never did that we just keep
competing cause like we're in the loop
all right i'm done
um
thank you guys so much i'll have
uh i'll see you guys later